hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control pe.l
2-3.10.3 escort visitors and monitor
visitor activity a challenging thing in
most offices
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all the cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it okay while this one seems pretty
intuitive I think the reality is that
most organizations today still do not do
a good job of monitoring the activity of
those people who are visitors that come
on site let's be honest you're just too
comfortable right so we want to make you
a little bit less comfortable you're
going to be doing business that is
defense related work okay National
Security level stuff you may not think
that you are you may not think that what
you do is so important but I promise
it's a big deal so yes your private
company and make may think to yourself
yeah we just make widgets here or
nothing to see here nobody would be
interested in me but hey I can tell you
have any level of success all right
enough to be even doing the Defense work
there are people including foreign
agents and competitors that would love
to know exactly how you operate and what
you're up to if you have a visitor in
the parking lot uh in the building
rather escort them at all times anything
short of doing that is a pretty big risk
for a lot of things from slip and fall
injuries to data exfiltration such as
what we were trying to prevent with
these standards okay just if you don't
have an eyeball on them crazy stuff
happens okay let's see what the assessor
is looking for on this one so we can get
a little more specific on what you got
to do uh first assessment Point
determine if visitors are escorted uh
again obviously we want to make sure
that our whole team is educated that if
they're bringing a visit in the building
that visitor's got to be basically duct
tape to their side when they're in the
building okay if we were to give an
answer this we would say hey it's
implemented per the it use and cyber
security policy all visitors are
escorted at all times while within the
secure facility now second assessment
Point determine if visitor activity is
monitored all visitor activity is
monitored by the visitors escort per the
itu since cyber security policy so
here's a big hint ding we use policies
to dictate this Behavior you're going to
need those policies because that's how
you're going to prove to an assessor
what it is your people are doing so if
you don't have a policy that talks about
how to handle visitors it's time to
write one if you want to write one
because it takes a whole bunch of time
and you don't know how to write policies
here's the good news give us a call and
when we help our clients with compliance
and are done for you format we actually
just simply deliver all the policies and
standard operating procedures complete
really done for you so if policy is a
thorn in your side we've got the answer
now at on-call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this dfars nist itar and cmmc compliance
stuff dropped in their laps like a
seagull on a sunny day and we teach you
how to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon so they have more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you and that's what we want
to help you with looking for more help
getting compliant our compliance experts
are always on call for you visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance nerds
roll it out again we're putting these
videos out here every day all day long
every week there's always something new
when it comes to compliance especially
in in this year uh you know with so many
sort of changes in Evolutions with cmmc
you really want to get some new
up-to-date source of information and we
are that for you okay until the next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you want to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
foreign
all right